I think the point and true value of brainstorming is often overlooked.
In our innovation process, it's the single most powerful tool that we use.
The first point of value that brainstorming gives us is that it allows us to create a huge volume of ideas...
...at the beginning of our process.
And improvisors really understand that we need to create a ton of ideas in order to find a few...
...exceptionally innovative ideas that can actually be implemented.
We use brainstorming to fill our idea pot,...
...to give us the ammunition and the fuel we need to move forward.
Brainstorming allows us to gather all of the different and diverse points of view at the top of our process too.
We absolutely know that the more diverse we can be at the top of our process,...
...the more robust and innovative our solution will be.
We use brainstorming to kick-start our process.
It's the rocket fuel that propels us towards the next great innovative idea.